it's like moving on from that i guess i
saw you uh got got some flack on like
tik tok the other day for like calling
what was it
like
a niche anime yeah i'm sure which
do you disagree i don't disagree i was
asked
sorry i agree that it is a niche anime
yeah so i was wondering why you were
getting flack for it that that
chihayofer is a niche anime have you
heard of it connor the one with the uh
yeah they're matching the card
yeah i'd say it's on borderline like i
know i know what it is but i mean like i
don't know well because like karutha is
like a
subculture where if you're really not
into i'd say japanese subculture then
it's hard to grow i'd say it's amazing
yeah it's pretty so i the reason well it
was just a very simple video where
they're like how do you prove that
you're the real pros of the and i was
like well i have a custom-made figure
from the niche anime chatroo which i
specifically when i was making it was
like at first i was going to say
i was like should i say obscure i was
like no if i say obscure
people are going to be like
and i was like okay i'll say niche
because niche is different than obscure
yeah niche just means like oh it's more
geared towards like a specific subset
yeah
niche can have a little more of a
positive obscure means not well known
like yeah
you know like not well-known yeah niche
is like oh it's more like uh this
audience than it's yeah yeah it's it's
it's definitely nice yeah whether it's
obscure i mean i even i might like i
might even call it obscure nowadays
because you look at like how popular
anime is nowadays and like 90 percent of
anime fans i think do not know children
i would say it's obscure for western
audiences oh yeah yeah you know in japan
it does really well yeah yeah but like
yeah you ask your average
anime fan okay which is again what
you're which i'm which i'm uh which
you're basically judging it right yeah
exactly if i ask like anime twitter yeah
you know what what chihayofuru is yes
you've heard of it right but if i ask uh
like you know i uh
in a
future later tick tock i was like yeah
i've been to i've been a guest at cons
and i'll do a q a it's like hundreds of
people i'll be like anyone here watch
chai furu
one guy yeah exactly right exactly
anyone know what it is like five people
you know yeah um
i mean i think i think a lot of people
who are like especially like anime fans
or like have been anime fans for a very
very long time they forget
how like
how un like how widespread it's become
now and how
some popular animes back in the day are
just like not well known now at all like
it's it's it's weird to think that even
like you know something like gurren
lagann is how many years old now and
about like 15 years it's like it's like
15 years old and that's that's that's
like i i would even say to like the mo
to like the modern anime fan like
that seems like a niche anime now i i
like a lot of new animals i remember you
just reminded me there was this moment
where i was like going on about like a
bunch of shows on on my twitch yeah and
then i started a poll oh we were talking
about haruhi
and i started a poll
saying because i saw a couple of people
being like i've never heard of it and so
i was like so i was like okay okay
mods starter pole
who has seen harry yeah and it was a it
was legit 50 50. wow
and i'm like and it just like put into
perspective like oh yeah like there's
been a lot of shows since haruhi yeah
yeah even though like for you know our
generation harrah he was like
inescapable right it was like it was
like the it was his show
yeah yeah i didn't really like haruhi
that much did you watch all of it i i i
you're gonna you're gonna be like yeah
of course i stopped watching during the
[ __ ] endless eight
oh of course of course
it was so boring that's the point
why the [ __ ] would i want to watch it if
it's boring it's art
i will say yo disappearance makes it
worth it yeah this makes the
disappearance of haruhi
is a [ __ ] amazing end i i so i told
these boys the story before but uh i
actually watched the disappearance
before i watched anything else
i was very confused and bored
and you know you want to know how it
happened
how
this was back when i just became an
anime fan right so naturally where am i
going to go to find recommendations for
shows yeah my anime list yeah yeah that
was one of the highest really highly
rated one of the highest like top five
rated things the disappearance of harry
suzumiya yeah i didn't know about any
other show
so i just watched it and i was like damn
this sucks ass why is everyone saying
this is good
i'm gonna kill you
i'm gonna absolutely kill you so this is
i watched it when i was like you know
17. did you also watch haruhi in
chronological order
[ __ ]
i watched it in the broadcast order i i
watched it in the actual order of the
episodes
yeah the broadcast
yeah yeah you saved yourself there yeah
at least so but this was like years
after i watched the disappearance yeah
did you watch this appearance again
afterwards i have not i should probably
do that huh yeah yeah
you need to finish
first yeah yeah you gotta i mean i will
say the best thing about it was probably
uh just like watching it like dub
crispin freeman was really good
yeah yeah even though he had no idea
what was going on yeah he was so good i
mean he's getting everything there yeah
yeah yeah i mean he's he's just one of
those voice actors where you just it's
just like a pleasure it's like yeah
just to hear him act but yeah i mean uh
that was okay
i i even the first season i was like
it's fine yeah did you watch avengers
end the game without watching anything
else that's actually a good confidence
that's actually a good comparison i i
watch some of the other things you know
okay oh some of them are good
i do watch kevin marvel you know um
yeah i'm sorry
[Music]
so what was the backlash significant
because you couldn't no
it wasn't it wasn't significant it was
just it was like anime fan backlash i
was just like also teasing but like you
know it was definitely
i'm sure you guys also do this too like
when i make a tweet sometimes i'm like
writing something i'm like okay i'm like
thinking of like how people be like well
actually well actually okay so change
this word to this yeah yeah they want to
like like i have to like explain the
joke or whatever or make it like clear i
don't mean this not this like to be
honest it's just not worth it because
like top 10 easiest things to do in the
world number one is breathe and number
two is piss off anime fans sure it's
just like not worth it i i feel like
there are like different levels right
because if you're talking about him off
like 10 seconds
you talk about most anime i feel like
there's some leeway but if you have an
opinion on any shonen anime then you are
literally like going to a battlefield
you know you are literally stepping on
my minefields at that point and yeah i
feel like any you say anything and
you'll get like some kind of backlash
sure it's also just really funny though
it is it is it is it is but you don't
watch many recent shows right you're
more you love the
classics it's not that i avoid recent
shows but it's more like
i have less time to watch stuff now so
for me it's more i want to pick and
choose right i pick and choose so and
uh
oh man i mean i'm at the perfect spot i
i do want to talk some anime so like
uh
yeah i don't i haven't seen like demon
slayer or jujutsu heisen yeah yeah and
it's not like i'm not going to watch
these things yeah it's more like
uh i don't know i'm watching uh
maria watches over us you know that one
no
that is uh that is the
yuri catholic
uh
high school girl anime
it's very good no no it's like watches
over us
that sounds fine
[Music]
or something might be the what the fans
call it or something it is a four season
show about uh
high school catholic girls and
yes oh this this is in 2004 holy [ __ ]
yeah i just watched the fourth season of
that uh like now this this is obscure
that's that's this is just like when i
when when i first met you speaking about
oh you like anime i was like yeah i like
anime he started naming shows and i was
like oh [ __ ]
i was like i don't i don't i'm not like
this kind of animation yeah i
no this is like before i started
watching things seasonally so
how did you find this anime so it's
funny you mentioned my anime list
i don't use my anime list i since i
since i first started my weeb journey
i've used anime news network's top anime
oh okay i didn't even realize they had a
top hat nobody does everyone uses my
anime list yeah yeah but anime news
network if you go to their um top
there's a top hundred and you can oh boy
it's i'm such a loser you can insert it
by buying us at like estimate and like
rank and it ranks it the top 500 right
right and like it does up like
that's how i find chia furu right uh i
go to that list for like what's on here
if if something pierces the top hundred
right i know it's worth watching so like
odd taxi pierce did right yeah or uh and
i watched that and yeah ranking of kings
pierced it yeah that's why i watched
[ __ ] amazing like
when i watch new stuff i'm like okay if
it hit the top hundred and on that
website yeah then i'm like something
special real [ __ ] yeah cause like i feel
like with a lot of the new [ __ ] that's
popular right now like things like demon
slayer and jiu-jitsu kaisen they're good
you know they're they're good and they
do well on that on that side like
because they're they're good i mean i
haven't seen them but i from what i
understand they're like good
quality
i feel like if you've watched any shonen
before it's it's kind of the same thing
it's the same formula it's just good
again yeah
shonen jump have just got this thing on
lockdown you've got the formula they've
just got the formula down because
anything anytime they release the show
it's always good you cut like you know
you kind of know what to expect there
there are like differences in every show
but you you get the same feeling every
time you know and so like you you don't
need to be you don't need to be in a
rush to watch like jiu-jitsu claisen
except if you just want to talk to
people about it nowadays you just want
to be in the inn yeah but like with a
lot of like more
obscure shows you know
is that the hot button i guess so i
guess i guess it is
so let's do it this show is very obscure
yeah
that is an obscure show my only problem
with my anime list is top 100 because i
have looked at it is that i feel like
new shows get favored really quickly yes
yeah like to be on anime news networks
like to get up there
it has to be like really good yeah where
sometimes i'll see stuff on there and
i'm like i'm sure it's good but i think
this is just on your because it's new
yeah
uh like and uh
my anime list also has this like weird
like
it it also gets weirdly political as
well because it's like there's this like
i've noticed there's this hardcore
dedicated group of people on my anime
list who are like if full metal
alchemist brotherhood is not number one
we riot wow yeah and it's like it's just
this dedicated group that just does
everything that they can to try and keep
certain shows in certain places yeah no
matter what see not enough people care
about anime news network's ratings
so it's actually like pretty accurate
yeah because i remember that happened
when your name came out yeah and it was
like it was getting really close to
being number one yeah and then there was
this whole like coup d'etat happening of
like no we must keep full metal
alchemist brotherhood at number one yeah
and then they succeeded yeah meanwhile
like the gintama fans would be like we
want every season of ginsama in the top
10.
here's the thing though like i haven't
i've only seen a little bit of gintama i
do intend to watch all of it at some
point yeah but it's amazing but getting
time all those seasons and movies those
pierce anime news network so i'm like
yeah yeah this has got to be they're all
great yeah yeah yeah yeah i do need to
watch that yeah so this tells a lot
about the type of person i am uh my goal
at one point is to have watched
everything in the top 100 on anime news
network okay oh okay so that's why i
watched maria watches over season four
that's why i finished have you seen i
mean i'm sure you have clinette clan ad
after story of course yeah i hadn't i i
didn't i watched clint clinton is it
clan
what clan ad clan ad yeah i watched it
like when it came out and i hadn't i
never finished it right yeah so like
season right yeah yeah because it wasn't
that good and then the the like like two
weeks ago i was like all right i'm gonna
finally watch it
and
that was i was surprised it was
surprisingly good that the after story
is very sad yeah it's yeah very sad that
last quarter without spoiling anything i
was like this is great i think it's fair
game spoiled
after i haven't seen off the what the
[ __ ]
yeah it turns into a different show yeah
yeah and it's great it's it's the build
up of the first season that makes the
second season
it was the first season that killed it
for me right now me too yeah it is with
a lot of people
you know i saw how a highly rated after
story was and i thought i'll i'll watch
it for after story yeah i i would never
normally watch planet nowadays yeah i'm
too yeah
yeah the planet season one is is pretty
tough to watch nowadays yeah yeah the
characters are like the worst archetypes
of every kind of anime person ever
except
kyo
yes i love cure yeah it was the best
okay
man yeah
okay yeah no i agree with you with my
anime this thing though with like it's
there's a lot of recency bias on there
where if there's like a new popular show
all right family getting like yeah yeah
yeah oh my god it's a 10 out of 10.
there's only three episodes out there
yeah
but like why it's quick sometimes i look
at the top 100 on my and i'm just like
am i the old one
is is it is the show that good or or am
i just like the the chris
what's one you feel that way about where
you're like he hasn't watched full
melakin's brotherhood really i okay i
haven't only read the manga i have okay
oh she's making excuses okay
everyone has that one show everyone has
that one [ __ ] you know don't tell me
you've only seen the 2003 anime i
haven't watched anything because okay
because because like the reason is that
like i remember like when i started
getting into anime you know you you you
watch banger off the banger off the bang
you're like anime is [ __ ] awesome
yeah and then you watch a bit more and
you're like
[ __ ]
am i gonna run out of good anime so so
like saving it for a rainy day yeah yeah
yeah so so i it mentally i was just like
i'm going to save fullmetal alchemist
because i know i'm going to like it i'm
going to save it for a raised bottom
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then and then
like it's just been years later and i
just i i know what you mean though
because i'm like that with hunter hunter
ah because it's like i i know so much
about the show just through osmosis that
like when i talk about certain parts of
the show people just think that i've
seen the show but i haven't actually sat
down and read it or watched it okay yeah
okay i get what you mean yeah so like
it's like an example i'm looking at the
list now and like the new season of
demon slayer is the 23rd best anime of
all time i'm just like did the new demon
slayer slap yes yes is this the 23rd of
all time is it the 23rd of all
time because people watched the last
three episodes the animation was insane
and they were just [ __ ] up like to
compare again this is going to be not
interesting well actually will this be
interesting to you i think it is this
would be interesting you still have
weebs listening to this yeah yeah yeah i
mean we stand up we like to pretend
every now and again that's uh
three you said you said that was 23rd
yeah yeah so to compare
on um anime news network uh
they are that is at let me pull it up so
to compare on anime news network that's
at like 209. but that's really good out
of the thousands of shows that have you
know yeah yeah i i [ __ ] love these
green balls it makes my i don't know why
it makes my [ __ ] brain go yeah you
know it's great right yeah i always had
these like really pleasing data bars
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so they do
like
arithmetic mean weighted mean begin
estimate
would i go all right i gotta look at
this list because like going down again
like you go to my anime news network
right
news network right now go to uh
oh no go to what is it
uh god so interesting uh
like i'm looking down i'm like 86 part 2
is the 46th best anime of all time no
no no no
no
i like 86 as well i like 86.
uh no i'm in it but i haven't seen it
that's a flex
um so go to encyclopedia click top ten
all right and then you can click the top
50 and you can go to like
top hundred and then there's 100 times
250 top 500. so right now brotherhood is
number one on there but i think that's
just it's quality
that's just that's just like crazy i do
think brotherhood i mean it's great it
is great it's a great package it's got
everything [ __ ] is better but it's
great yeah it's got everything yeah
it does everything amazingly in this
yeah it's a great show and it's you know
it's it chose it was like we're gonna be
64 episodes we're gonna do it perfectly
yeah so let's compare someone pull up my
anime list top 10. you got it oh okay i
had it yeah yeah so and i'll i'll
compare the top ten on anime news
network sorry both uh so both number
ones are formula
number two on here is stein's gate oh
that's interesting it was like it wasn't
that my anime was for a while uh number
two on here is gintama
one of those let's go
okay number three steins gate actually
number three on here is clanette after
story oh okay clown number four is your
name
okay yeah um number four on this one is
attack on titan season three part two
okay number five on yours roney kenshin
trust and betrayal that's the samurai x
zoe yeah yeah i'm just gonna say it
number five number eight number nine are
all guinta jesus
what are you doing for him yeah boy
number six on here is code geass season
two which sucked ass but that's fine
yeah at the end the ending the ending
the whole show sucks
[Music]
i can't think of a better ending
that's pretty good
that's true that's true i think i think
what you said could be true if that's
the only anime you've ever seen
i can't believe i'm getting called out
uh seven is spirited away then cowboy
bebop number nine is mushishi season two
yeah yeah which is very good
which is very good mushy she's like see
like from this one it's like number
seven is like the new kagia summer which
i don't think has even ended it's not
finished yet yeah that's my problem with
this list yeah yeah yeah you gotta wait
until the show's done yeah right the
show could turn to a big big turd like
you know
you've also gotta give it some time
after it's finished too so that like
people can like process processor yeah
yeah i read the miami list reviews when
there's only like two episodes out
they're like i'm gonna review the whole
show now i'm just gonna yeah yeah
i love i love the miami list reviews of
people who drop the show
yeah and they're just like i watched the
two and a half episodes of this and i
thought it was absolutely fantastic ten
out of ten it's like all right